[Music]
i like gt actually
i prefer the q4
better turning radius
have a nice day sir
i can't do this goodbye vincent
goodbye then
olivia please don't go out front there's
paparazzi you're being reckless call me
when you're divorced
are you all right people are looking i
never thought i would get hit by a
podcast
in five days i can't help this getting
out there what if we find the other guy
in the photo and we would pretend to be
a couple
i'll do it for lady island is going to
go out with me the famous actress yes
the beautiful one yes with me correct
my sister would you up to this you got
me
shout out get ready
say something i'm gonna laugh really
hard i don't understand
are you some kind of sex guy antonio i'm
not a sex guard
[Music]
what's happening here
[Music]
antonio
what do you see in my brother he's
decent and kind
of i love you i'm famous too which is
surprisingly hard to find
[Music]
was that your ex i have been trying to
get her back now big gems maybe we'll
look for what we want out of this
insanity
oh my god when he's here
oh god no nothing happened
and i slept in my pants
see
[Music]